-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy Award-winning comedian
who's currently
in his 18th season
on "Saturday Night Live."
He also stars in the new
comedy series "Kenan,"
which airs Tuesday nights
at 8:30 right here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-So, the fairy cursed
Sleeping Beauty
to sleep for a hundred years
Sound like the best curse ever
Until the Prince arrived
to try to awaken
Sleeping Beauty
out of her slumber.
-Princesses are dumb.
-What?
When did this happen?
-Recess. Princesses are out.
Empowerment is in.
-Will you sing us a song
about that, please?
-[ Sighs ] Okay. Uh...
♪♪ Title Nine ♪♪
♪♪ You are so fine ♪♪
♪♪ Famous for your place
in athletics ♪♪
-Both: Yeah, no.
-Please welcome back to the show
one of the best.
Kenan Thompson.
How are you, Kenan?
-I'm good, buddy.
How are you doing?
-I am wonderful
and got a little bonus "Kenan"
last night.
You did "SNL" on Saturday,
you flew to L.A.,
and then you did the Golde
Globes last night with Maya.
And it just must have been
a delight to be with Maya again.
-Absolute best.
It was the absolute best, just
being around my sisters again --
you know, Tina,
you know, Amy and Maya.
-For those who missed it,
can you tell us a little bit
about the characters
you guys played last night
-Yes, that is Beverly Jackfrui
on the left
and Francois Jean-Rudy
on the right.
That is me.
And I speak French only.
And we were the winners
of Least, I think, Creative Song
or, like...
-I think Least Original.
Maybe Least Original.
-Least Original, yes.
Least Original.
-It was really fun to see.
It must have, you know --
Obviously it was extremely
difficult circumstances
to do an awards show.
But it was like being
in front of any audience,
like you guys have managed
to do with "SNL."
It's still something special
-Yeah, it's nice to have,
you know,
some people in the room
and not, like, totally virtual
But, you know, it was
really isolated backstage,
and I didn't really see
anybody famous.
You know what I'm saying?
My first time at the Globes,
and I saw just me.
It was like, "Okay, well.
Is this the Golden Globes
or is this my house?"
-I'm very --
I want to talk about your show
because I'm very jealous about
a famous person on your show
who I have never met,
and that person is Don Johnson
who is very funny on your show
And I'm just wondering,
is he a fun person to be aroun
in real life?
-Don Johnson is the greatest
Like, he could not be nice
and he could not have
better stories.
I mean, this guy was in Miam
in the '80s and survived.
And he just loves to laugh
you know,
and we got really close,
over our FaceTime meeting
when I first met him.
You know, we just had, you know,
just similar energy.
I don't know how to explain it
He's just a nice guy, you know
And I've been a fan of him
you know, since those days
I was a little kid,
but I knew he was cool,
and to find out that he's cool
in real life was just great.
-Yeah, 'cause they were --
I forget that they, of course,
were shooting "Miami" for Miami,
and if you were
a fan of that show,
that meant you were
a certain kind of person
who probably wanted to hang ou
with Don Johnson.
-Yeah, you either like Ferrari
or you like guns
or you like blazers
with colorful undershirts.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- You also returned
one of my favorite character
on "SNL" last week, LaVar Ball
-Oh. Crazy.
-You do seem to be
having a genuine ball
when you are doing
this character.
Is it as much fun as it looks?
-It really is,
and I think that's kind of
my overall approach to "Update,"
especially when I'm nervou
about something.
Because I haven't done LaVar
in a while,
and it's kind of
a niche kind of character.
Like, not a lot of people
know exactly who he is.
So the more energy I give to it,
people can just have fun
with it without even knowing
like, kind of,
who I'm talking about
or whatever.
So, the shoe helps.
The chocolate shoe, the cookie
the caramel in the shoe.
Like, all those
little crazy additives
help everybody enjoy the fac
that there's comedy happenin
and you should just enjoy it
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, because if he wasn'
a real person,
he would also be a fantastic
original character on "Update.
So you guys definitely
make it work both ways.
-Thank you very much.
The Cara-mellos!
Also put Charlotte on the map.
I heard so much from Charlotte
people over the weekend.
They were like, "Thank you
for shouting out Gastonia.
-How do you like --
How are you enjoying sitcom life
for being a guy
who didn't just do 18 year
or hasn't just done
18 years of "SNL" sketches
but was doing sketches
for years before that?
How is sitcom life?
-It's very different.
You know, it's like --
As soon as I come to work,
we start shooting
and we're shooting all day
So it's, like, performance
every day, all day
as opposed to, like,
"Saturday," you know,
we have writing headaches
or whatever,
and then, like, rehearsal,
but it's still kind of casual.
We're in our clothes,
like, our normal clothes
as opposed to hair and makeu
all week, you know?
So it's a bit of a grind.
I mean, they're both different
I think "SNL" is more mental
and sitcom is probably
a lot more physical.
Like, a lot more physical.
-You have two young daughter
in real life.
Have they come to set yet
to meet your TV daughters?
-Unfortunately, no,
and they are dying to.
They talk about them
all the time.
They're, like,
so intrigued by them.
You know, it's like,
"So are they us or are we them?"
It's like, "No, sweethearts.
You guys are
separate individuals.
This is television."
But, yeah, my big girl, Georgia,
she's obsessed with the show
She thinks it's really cool.
-I guess it's good
that they haven't been abl
to come to set yet,
because sometimes, Kenan,
don't take offense to this
you do not behave
the way a father should.
-I've been acting up lately.
-Yeah, so, our friend,
Mike O'Brien,
who was a writer at "SNL"
and now is the creator
of the show "AP Bio" --
you stopped by his parking spot?
And, Kenan,
do you want to explain?
-Yeah, I saw his parking spot,
and I thought
I'd take a little photo.
[ Laughter ]
Just to show him a little love
-Yeah.
-So, you know, I can't wai
until he sees this.
[ Laughter ]
-This is the first
he'll be seeing it?
-Absolutely.
-Kenan, I realized something
right before you came on.
This is our 1,111th show.
11-11.
And if memory serves,
you were married 11-11-11.
-So, 1-11 is a big number
for my wife.
She's big on the number 3.
I was big on the number 33
So, yeah, 11-11-11 came up
and we wanted
to get married on that date.
My dressing room for the Golde
Globes was 111 yesterday.
And, yeah, it's kind of a thin
that, you know, circulates us.
I can't believe I'm on
your episode, on 1,111.
Like, that's incredible.
But congratulations to you
That is so many checks.
[ Whistling ]
-Thank you.
When somebody told me
it has been 1,111 shows,
I said,
"Give it to me in checks.
I don't want to hear
how many shows I've done."
-Count it in checks, please.
-Hey, buddy, thanks as alway
for being here.
Congrats on all your shows
And great job again last night
-Man, thank you so very much
It was a great weekend.
It's great to see you as always.
I love you. I miss you.
I'm sure I'll see you soon
-I'll bet.
I'll see you
back in the building.
"Kenan" airs Tuesdays
at 8:30 p.m. here on NBC.